they hello everybody my name is very
polite okay my name is Cheryl I'm a
computer vision researcher at eBay
previously to that I was consulting in
company name Corrigan I was on my way to
University of Southern California when
eBay decided to purchase this company
and Here I am so today we were talking
about generative models in general and
variational auto encoder which is my
favorite personal favorite generative
model in particular so what we'll see
today is what is wrong with
discriminative models right what is the
great thing about variational turn
coders and I can compete with I swear I
will again all right how variational
encoders can be improved using Gant and
I know a lot of people have heard about
Gunn and there is a lot of talk talk
about Gann the term I'm here to make
order and mass maybe so let's start this
is what we're not going to talk about
today we are not going to see the lower
down stuff so no heavy mathematics just
intuition right so which is Feynman said
what I cannot create I do not understand
he's some kind of famous physic guy I
don't know like a wizard but that is not
too far away from the truth because
everybody see that a lot of the models
today can generate like high really
really realistic images and some people
get really excited about that and some
people just don't know why they should
because I
about that so I'm here to show you the
way why should be excited when you see
this right so here it is some of you of
we do this slide by result hand who is
who knows this this nobody no one really
no one okay this was the best actor
award was 2015 by Nvidia and basically
by everybody else who's using deep
learning in this time the title of this
this paper was wires oil deep learning
models or easily food how to fold deep
learning models right so they pulling
out something really trivial and when
you when you when when you are training
discriminative models right the square
root of all those are kind of models
integrating you presenting the input and
you can expect one output for example
either the dog or a cat okay so then
presenting and discrete is a model all
you trying to see all you trying to
calculate is just a height of thing
anything on the left is dog everything
on the right is a cat okay you don't
really understand how dogs and cats look
like but all you have all you're left
with is just a hyperplane editing and
left is one and Kindle devices second
like so this is actually really old
relaxation when people invented the
logistic regression they actually did
this relaxation and they were very proud
of that because we say they said
actually computing the joint probability
of x and y together is really hard so
let's try to calculate the conditional
probability and the conditional
probability is just let's let's talk
about conditional probability is
actually mapping directly to decide to
think when you calculate in conditional
probability you say don't really
understand I don't really care about the
joint probability of x and y together
I don't we
want to model this cluster but I will
only a model this hyperplane that
divides between two clusters right so
every time doing discriminative orders
this is what you're doing you just
calculate in a hyperplane and single the
left is a everything on the right is B
you really don't you don't know anything
about grouping good B you just know how
to separate them right so what is one of
the distinctive models in general not
just deep learning models discriminative
model as they are okay so let's start
with an example and this is the example
for the same paper
we all see here school bus right and
here the same the same school bus in all
right right saying hey there is kind of
a chicken here and some some kind of the
dental here same image in our eyes is
the same which left and right but I can
tell you that the right image is the
left image plus some noise this is not
random noise but this light is
calculated and at the end of this
lecture you will know how to calculate
this specific noise that makes the
picture on the right to the network
placed the network now think that this
agent left is a school bus and the image
of the right can either by guess what it
is
ostrich right 99.99 percent ostrich this
is what the net people think about these
images and this is I mean ridiculous
phosphorus right no I actually don't
know who wrote that but it's super
famous just search for deep learning or
easily fooled best paper Volvo 2015 you
see this is not an opening I'm not real
good self
and then they did some more tricks to
trick the neural networks and this list
will make sense right these ones does
look like button and remote and core
control and you can feel the metal thing
that this one is a remote control right
and this is some kind of starfish but
it's totally unorganized but to us but
this dislike it's like very weird the
network thing that this one this noise
right here is armadillo 99.99 percent
accuracy
it's confident like really confident
that this one is a little the question
is why
so we go a little bit back and this poor
reason of why it because we are not
modeling the clusters recognized the
image we are moving away the only thing
you want you need to do in order to fool
discriminative model any disco music is
model it just move away from the cluster
of the wheel distribution of the images
take it away
down below to the left of the earth to
the hyper plane this is the hyper plane
which is just any picture in this area
will be complete noise and we're very
confident that the network will say that
all these guys are armadillo for working
for voles yeah so we get the basic idea
of what's wrong with destroy native
model and this is not entirely true
because people have done some good work
with discriminative model regardless of
what I'm saying or what this paper is
saying but the basic idea it gets more
acute we're using deep learning models
alright the dimensionality increase
dramatically and it's it is much easier
to fold Allah talks right so
once we establish that this creative
model are not the things you want to do
when you're doing the deep learning we
will move forward to generative model
and another thing that we see further
had that apply employing structure on
the latent spacing generative model is
also very good trick that you can do
right the reason why is like many doing
genetic models people have shown that
you can use generative models with same
supervised learning to cakes and get
very very close to state-of-the-art with
like to order of magnitude less label
data all right for example in on a
missed the hand digit dot set these guys
will invent variation a lot encoder can
got really close to the state of the art
we just can label that data points
instead of five thousand five thousand
data points right so it's three order of
magnitude less big data so let's start
for the finish this is this from the
paper of variational base autoencoders
to exactly what we will talk about today
what you see here is like a Gaussian
distribution view from the top right and
this is actually the latent space of the
rotation of the digits here all right so
this is this like beginning from the end
this is what we want you what we want
actually is to map our entire data
points okay to a Gaussian distribution
all right completely Gaussian
distribution and as every cent this
whole process is completely unsupervised
so the training phase does not see the
labeling the labeling here is like 1 0
to 9 the you can see that it get it got
most of them really good reading really
really good all the views are clustered
here together and all the ones here down
here
servants or dollar you get really good
separation of the data points with
almost this one generated without any
supervision right and then if you have
diesel betting if you have this
translation of image pixels to displace
to this two-dimensional Gaussian you can
use any super semi-supervised
semi-supervised to click write almost an
SMS or voice to collect label
propagation or anything you want and it
get really good results like really good
results okay so by raise your hand who
knows auto-encoders basics right cool
right so we will try to move away from
autoencoders to variational or encoders
which is just like a little little thing
you'd put on top and get variational to
encoder and everybody will be happy and
go on to something
okay so auto encoder on college in
general built a bit from two part then
call the network we get a lick put and
we try to map it to some later space
domain
okay embedding space feature space I
don't know I don't care how you call it
and then much once you have the
embedding space right in place you try
to weaken start the same input right so
far so good so what is the difference
between autoencoders and version onto
encoders is it just like this guy here I
am employing some structure I'm
constrained destroy the later space to
be Gaussian normal distribution this is
done with this drawing difference like
so what do I need to represent Gaussian
I noticed two things mean and variance
right we need the mean vector and viral
vector
so I take my cat right i encoded to
using this encoding network which is
just convolutional network or fully
connected Network I don't ever tease but
this network will output two vectors
mean vector and started deviation right
and then once I have these these two
guys in place I will just sample from it
the actual representation and this is
the variational part right and then once
I have this latent vector the
precipitation of a to the feature vector
I the only thing I need to do is we can
start the same image for example if if I
didn't do this one this is all day is
only three blocks reading you if it was
just encoding to do a latent vector and
just across pocket it was just open
coder but these three blocks just did
the combustion process of using mean
vector publication sample for it
transform this auto encoder to valuation
remote encoder right things okay so far
so I don't know how to how much time do
we have so we'll skip the questions but
again basically what is the problem here
and the problem is that sampling from a
distribution random sampling is not
continuous is not things that you can
back okay to it this long thing so this
guy's way these guys are pitted direct
Kingma and in max reading these guys
right here actually the same idea came
out from to get from two separate places
in roughly the same time from google
deepmind and this does but actually
combine much waiting was was hitting the
points right right away and i like that
their paper better so their permit rapid
motivation trick basically the original
forms like we have mean and started
deviation and you want to sample for it
and this dissipation is not a
differentiable you can better get to
this listing so what they do what they
did it is just you want you want
something around the mean vector
all right you mean vector you have
standard deviation they said just let's
stretch the standard deviation with some
random noise with Epsilon
okay and wants to stretch and standard
deviation with thumbs with some noise
just add it to the mean vector and then
you get from this is actually equivalent
to two random sampling right but this
equation is totally linear I can
calculate the gradient with respect to
MU and Sigma really easily it's a linear
equation it's nothing nothing weird
about that so they did the random
sampling to something that is a totally
deterministic and not totally because
you do sample epsilon but it's it's
almost a termina stick and you can die
propagate it like really easy so this is
the whole Ripper motivation trick in two
sentences so we cap number one what was
so so far is we so often go to the Gulf
and later space this is the on things so
before so far and how to sample
formulated space distribution the right
way right this next we will add some
constraint of the later space actually
we will try to move the Gaussian with
latent space to normal distribution 0
mean unit variance and then we would say
couple things about why it's so cool to
have unit variance no a unit variance in
the feature space and then lastly but
only lastly we will talk about again
just two slides about gap okay
some background before KL divergence
basically clear divergence is weighted
sum on some similarity measures of
measurement okay some people some crazy
people actually turns 10 to modify the
similarity measure but we don't care
about that all I want you to have in
mind
basically the versions is like pushing
one distribution P to Q okay
it has an equation if you want the
details you can look for it but once
what I want you to have in mind when I
say care divergence which is pushing P
floats Q okay we have two distribution T
which is the actual distribution of the
representation of the images in the
latent space and want to push it towards
normal distribution zero mean and
variance note by changing X by changing
the representation of X okay the
encoding network just transform X to
some latent of the same representation
and I want that the latent with
representation will be a normal
distribution okay this is the condition
the other constraint so now this is this
is actually the full variation on
auto-encoders from bottom to top we
start here at the bottom right this is
like this is all you have to know to
build your own variation on what encoder
you start with your input X you pass it
through the encoding network which is
just the convolutional neural network
with two output to vector output for
each challenge one of them is the new
the mean and the other one is the
standard deviation then we have the
Ripper motivation tweak we start the
randomly epsilon and we skill Sigma with
this appear epsilon and add you to it
and then help read the actual or
presentation of the image okay
stochastic representation of the image
right and then we try to decode it we
get X tilde wig stand and we want that
ink mix that would be as close as
possible to each other the other thing
that we are doing is we saying that you
want me Sigma to be as close as possible
in Cal divergence sense right to normal
distribution the oming unit audience
right so this is how you get done from
head to toes any question
No excellent so it would be 30 means
again what is the problem here and this
is like the last part of going little
bit to gun here's the hint no one and
now enter these tanks in pixel space
okay if we if you if we actually do how
to build similarity function between two
images
I would I would not be standing here
right now we will all be out of job
so Alto distance in pixel space is like
it doesn't it's nothing it's most of the
time it's nothing right so if we
actually knew how to build good
similarity measurement between images
alright so we will I would give time in
here so this is just an example of what
I'm trying to say this is the visuals
and original image right in this in this
image I was just taking just a little
bit of a volume from each pixel and I
got 15 50k pixel while different fashion
between the origin and using this image
and this one I just blacked out one
square and a goat on 10k difference in
the pixel space so l2 distance said that
these two are mostly that this lot more
similar this one the right with the
black square is no similar to the
original image which which is obviously
false right so here we go to gun as I
promised just two slides about gap okay
this is fine summit chintala blog
basically what you do is take a
generative model and a disconnected
model and let make them fight actually
let's talk about it just a little bit
we with variational turncoat we already
have genetic model right with generic
images and now we have another another
discriminative model which try to
distinguish between generated images and
real images one of them are label one
and the other are labeled zero we all
know that deep models are doing fairly
different job in this community stuff
images in particular right so what
happens if the discriminative network is
doing poorly doing a [ __ ] job right it
might be one of the two one case this
model is not good enough it's not strong
enough but it's deep learning model it's
supposed to be it's supposed to handle
everything right so it might it must be
the case that this task is very very
hard and if the task is very very hard
this mail that you're generated images
are almost indistinguishable from the
real images and this is what this loss
function actually does it
Gong actually comes to replace this pull
this unrealistic loss function right
this is what gun does the disconnect
event network come to come to replace
this shitty really shitty thing loss
function so it will place - your loss
function so if you don't know how to
construct loss function you should look
into gun as a last result but if you do
want to construct your loss function
very good
don't your gun right this is my main
this is it's not to take away in the end
but it's take away for not for now
because they get a lot of I don't know
click and people come to an interview
with at eBay and we say what the cost
what is the cost angel we've been
working with lately and everybody says
gun so I tell them what but do you use
gung-ho and like
very little very few actually know that
gun is here to replace your loss
function they can construct gun they can
code it they can show you everything
from the generative model and the
discriminative model and if they will
let them code they will code it like
perfectly but they note they don't fully
understand that the only thing that the
gun does is just replace your loss
function right so here is the
variational note encoder together with
gun so you have the input you encode it
to the latest page read with the
variation on trick as we talked before
you decode it and get X tilde and then
you have X net filter two rivals and you
put them to the distributor network and
try and at the discriminative network to
label X tilde as 1 and X of 0 I should
distinguish between the 22 so this one
this part is the variational tone total
part and this one is the Gamper you see
if there is overlapping right so just
one one one last question and I'm
promised this is the end why do we why
do we love normal distribution 0 mean
unit variance what what the unit
variance stand for well it actually
stands for that it inclines
in the pair exactly I like you it
implies that your feature our
independence this is this is like
straight forward if you have unit
variance of your features this mean that
epic two features that are the Terek two
features are are not correlated this is
what it means because when you do dot
product with in between two features to
to a sampling from two different
features you get 0 which means this
means then they are not correlated so we
actually represent you image to an
uncorrelated feature space meaning that
each feature captures
one specific and unique attribute of the
feature of the image and this is like
this is the most basic thing that you
will ever see
right and this is this is what this
light talks about you see these sad
faces right and these happy faces all
they did here is just like moving a
single feature from the feature space
one one feature let's say you have
feature space in a length of 100 you
just moved one feature and the we can
start the image and from input of sad
faces they get output of happy faces I
mean this is this is very impressive
I was blown away by that exactly for
each feature you get unique and
meaningful most of the time initial Sun
all the time it would be not meaningful
but you have to play with each feature
and see what it caught some of them will
cut will catch garbage like lighting and
I have known some good stuff but some of
them will be very interesting right so
this one is like wow and actually this
is I'm pretty sure some of you saw this
slide before this is for my disconsolate
chin tail again and actually like what
you can do with this hyper space this
good this embedding space is actually do
some arithmetic you can take smiley
women - natural women your presentation
in the later space and add some natural
men presentation in the later space in
the Gaussian space minus plus and get
smile men which is amazing I don't know
in my eyes deceive sly man smile women -
natural McLoughlin x equals smiling man
same as water looks like
and if we will go away we're home and
try to get in this page this is like
Peter do like Kidman they also of one of
the two other very short encoders and
you will click on this demo page you
will see how amidst embeds into twelve
is twelve left twenty feet of length of
foot twelve feature vector and you can
play with each feature vector just a
little bit and see what it captured some
of them capturing the the stock width
but more fun when did this how do we
paint how do you paint the actual letter
is it skewed to the left or skewed to
the right how tall it is each of each
feature captures something distinct and
unique in the characters characteristics
of the painting of the image right um as
an added bonus actually how much telling
to us but how much time do you five
minutes right this is perfect I will
skip this one and go to icon explained
in sparkling it's alright I'm sure some
of you actually know this this paper I
mean this is very recent people from
Berkeley University and what they did is
just add some constraint on the latest
pace but actually it's very cool paper
and you see how it works in like five
minutes because we know all the till to
each right now so how I can works in
five minutes
you just take an image you project it to
the Leighton space right and once you
project this specific image the leg to
the Leighton space you are solving two
constraints equation one of them saying
you know what I want a different image I
want a new image which is close enough
to them bedding points I want to see if
this point just got embed to
this section I want to stay near this
section right the other thing is just I
want that the output image will have
this feature characteristics okay so the
thing that you do is you just do
gradient descent from the pixels you
have pixel constraints and you have lake
and space constraints you have two
constraints this is it the pixel
constraint says I want these lines to be
green I want this area to be green and I
want the mountain over here and slow in
blue sky and everything
this one this part you can do by
gradient fences of the day image you get
some generated image and then you say
you know what I want the generated image
will have this characteristic anyway and
get some air function and get some air
gradients propagated back to the latent
space and this is just in the L
gradients just let you move around this
space little bit to the left over to the
right but but and when you move in this
latent space it will actually get these
pixel constraints satisfied but
additionally you don't want to move too
far away from the original image and
this is what you get this is eigen
explained in five minutes right like
we'll cool paper not a lots of new stuff
from this paper specifically books they
get back on a lot of a previous work and
it's excellent and the other thing that
I promised we things that there will be
some code examples all right so we I'm
getting there right now don't worry at
the powers we want to fold in your
networks and we can do that like with
three lines of code when we try when we
are training neural network we are
actually optimizing data let's say that
f is our neural network then your
training neural network we're trying to
find the best parameter theta that
can satisfy that f of X parametrized by
theta x equals y this is what we do we
optimize theta and let's say we have the
pre-training network we know the weights
are good and everything is good one
don't want to touch the network now we
want to actually modify X okay
want to modify X we fix Y to be ostrich
so let's say that X is cool is a school
bus all right and now we say that you
know what I don't want that these
pictures pathetically will be school bus
I want to I want it to be an ostrich
right so you get an one heart of the
sensation of the of the ostrich you fit
for the X to the network and the Delta
cells okay it's the school bus I know I
know this guy this is a school bus right
so you get L gradients right and and you
propagate back all the way to the image
right you optimize X with this loss
function and in codes it's like three
lines of code people just people
everybody considers can you turn off the
light weight another okay so so this is
the network this is like getting the
actual prediction of the network this is
me telling the network you know what a
goddess of your prediction we want that
this picture will be us which is the
label right and then this is the coat
art and what the gradient with respect
to the inputs this is the oil different
basically what you get if you calculate
when you train an annual you do type in
you get in the gradient with with
respect to these parameters so now I
want to gradient with respect to the
inputs you get the X and then you're
just doing great innocence for a couple
of time and get 99.99 delicacy all right
so we take aways in points to our show
your own your vegetation space is like
super cool super important with
Darabont ization trick so basically when
you when you are using gaussian latent
space of the presentation in some sense
you adding volume to your to your a data
point each data point instead of being a
mapped to a single distinct point you
adding volume to it because it's now
instead of being one point it's a sphere
it's a Gaussian right and gong-gong
actually super cool but it's only come
to replace your loss function so if you
know how to build your own loss function
don't use gun if you don't know how to
build you your boss function try harder
and if you have a find it your gun okay
because gonna check it to to Train
everybody know that and the personal
takeaways it just doesn't work for the
first time nothing does okay so try and
try until it works and another thing is
like I took some slide from this cool
young guy he's 16 years old from Palo
Alto his name is Kevin France he has
like amazing dog with all the coolest
latest papers explaining one or two
pages and he was 16
he's [ __ ] amazing right so I
encourage every with each and every one
of you just go to his dog it's Katie
forms a calm and check checking out it's
like amazing and you will have access to
these slides and here's a pretty
comprehensive a reference list right and
that's it between actually I'm done we
aren't hiring eBay is hiring like crazy
right now
everything from full stop developers and
back-end researchers joining researchers
everything you want eBay has a place for
you so just contact me send me an email
and I will folder to the white people
and this is it thank you
[Applause]